i guess i guess uh
i guess that's what you guys were doing
in the off time of uh not actually
hosting the show here now we know i mean
that was
first of all i'm not gonna lie aaron
that red wig looked a little too natural
i'm just gonna say it it looked good so
and let's talk about the tournament uh
yeah let's do it
we have come a long way to get here and
now we
are here the final day and we're gonna
start out with a third
place match rustage and the anime man
made it to the semi-finals and
unfortunately were defeated by their
courts
uh and will face off for a chance at
doubling the prize money from that four
hundred dollar
fourth place prize to thr uh to eight
hundred dollars for third
and uh and then i guess the match that
everybody
knew they had to wait for a sea dog
versus gigg a lot of people
had their fingers crossed i think for
this uh for this matchup right jt
oh yeah um they were basically
predicting that it would be
conor and car in the championship match
and
the prophecy came true so i'm excited
well i i didn't even know that when i uh
i have to say for the record i did not
know who the strongest player was of
these anime
superstars when i predicted that conor
would be
uh in the final i said i was rooting for
him after i did that anime dubbing
video so i'm i'm excited that that that
worked out i'm i'm also
you know in the i you know so i made my
my my camp clear on camp connor
but also i'm excited to see what giga
can do he's um
he like like you said aaron in our
pre-show he's a very patient player
i think it was a great highlight moment
in the twitter video showing him take
two thousand years to make sure he
didn't deliver stalemate
right i mean i mean but he's a but will
that pay off right sometimes patience
you know can really be um a key skill
against a guy who maybe maybe knows he's
the better player maybe that makes
connor a little overconfident at times
and can take advantage of it so i'm i'm
pretty excited to see what they
delivered of course
we're sitting here talking about the
final i mean we have rustage and uh joey
the anime man coming up first
we do and you know you did tease that
you did this uh
this voice over video so anyone who has
not had a chance to check that out
run over to our youtube channel uh
that's youtube.com
chess find this thumbnail and you
will i don't know enjoy this but before
we uh before we get those games started
we're going to actually talk to russege
and the anime man we're going to bring
them on
right before their match because they
both decided that they
they wanted a little bit of air time to
say whatever they might
have on their mind so we are going to
cut to a very quick break we're going to
bring on those players
we'll have a conversation and then we
will kick off the third place match so
everybody stay tuned
we will be back very shortly
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and we're back and we brought the
players with us russian uh the anime man
what's up guys
hello hey what's up how are you guys
doing we're doing great so you have uh
you have a match coming up and um i i
guess
my first question is like uh what was
the preparation did you
rustic did you get some rest i'd okay
so i didn't take a nap but what i did do
is after my
game last night i slept for 12 hours uh
and i woke up at 4 p.m
and yeah i know i've been awake since
then but that's not been terrible so
i'm a bit more well-rested than i was
yesterday but
yeah i played any games between uh
i played two practice games okay hey
what about you joey any practice
um i did a couple of puzzles um
on the chess.com thing just to like
familiarize myself with more patterns
um but yeah other than that i just got
myself some good rest because
man my brain was hurting after yesterday
well danny i know you're probably happy
to hear that uh the boys are using that
puzzle trainer
yeah i was gonna say if i was giving
advice to someone sometimes one of the
best things to do right before
a game or a tournament is is just puzzle
sharpness so that you
eliminate some of the other noise that
can happen and just zone in on the pure
tactics but
i i just want to say i'm super excited
to be here for the finals we've been
watching you guys i've been watching you
guys
and i wanted to ask i mean do you guys
feel like over the last couple weeks do
you feel like you're seeing chess
differently now at a higher level than
you did maybe at the beginning when we
first
made this announcement of the tournament
arc and and and this whole idea i mean
i'll ask
i'll ask you rustage first where you
feel you've come over the last couple
weeks
i mean for sure i mean a few weeks ago i
didn't even know
anything about chess and now i'm i i can
see things i could never see before
you know i still can't see everything
but now when i look at the chess board i
could
you know it sort of becomes this more
it's like magic right you could sort of
see the pieces in the different spaces
and where they could be
like like glowy blue holograms of chess
pieces and stuff if that makes sense i
don't know if that makes sense
it sounds great i thought you're about
to start telling me you've been hearing
colors and seeing sounds
like that but that sounds pretty
mystical i like it i wish i could see
the chessboard like that no i'm kidding
good stuff so jt you uh you whispered a
little
uh final advice to your student uh
before we
before we went live uh you wanna you
wanna tell us about that
uh do you want me to say it in japanese
or do you want me to say it in the
translation
now i say it in japanese so that yeah
okay okay japanese first santo
gabaranaito
and now you have to give us a false
translation so that we're not giving
away the secret right
i actually like one piece
is great love one piece
it's my favorite manga oh oh
joey i guess i guess the question the
follow-up there is uh
how do you feel the advice uh that
you've gotten over the last few days
from from jt has
has it guided you oh yeah definitely i
mean
i'm kind of in the same thing as rust
where i before this tournament i've
never even touched a chess
piece in my life so yeah i the the
amount of appreciation i've grown
towards this game and just like the
intricacies of it and
obviously you know thanks to jt's help
with uh guiding me through that but uh
yeah it's it's been really really fun
you know
um you know regardless of whoever wins
or loses today i think it's just gonna
be a really enjoyable time and
uh yeah i'm excited for it well uh
yeah danny go ahead i was gonna say i
have a follow-up on that because the way
you said that joey was interesting to me
that you i mean you're obviously
someone who's very good at what you do
in a completely different field and i
and i always wonder when people
dive into chess if there's a tipping
point
where sort of the fact that the lid has
been blown off about how complicated it
is
does that inspire you and make you just
excited to kind of be at a level where
you're learning so much or sometimes
that overwhelming and and
does that make you want to like does it
make you want to keep playing chess
after this event or does it make you
like all right
i had my two weeks now i need to take a
breath and take a step back from this
game like how does that how do you feel
about that
um i i think it's a little bit of both
honestly like i i definitely do want to
like keep
this momentum going even after the
tournament just because i do
feel like getting good at chess is like
a skill set that
really will be beneficial to other
things that i do and other things i
might get into and i've always
i've always loved trying new things um
so yeah just getting into this whole
thing has always been just super
interesting
to me but uh i don't know if i'm gonna
be like as intensely playing chess after
this tournament because i don't think my
brain can handle it
but yeah you would be you would be both
buddy that's why i commentate and don't
play so
yeah yeah exactly but like you know now
i now i you know have the excuse to be
like hey
you know you want to play a small game
of chess with my friends now because i
always felt so out of the loop when
all of my friends could play chess
except for me but now i can finally like
join in on them and hopefully
show them a little bit of my
quote-unquote skills
with chess well russiage the anime man
we're going to let you go because in a
few minutes
your minutes we're going to kick off
those games so good luck to both of you
and we'll talk to you after the match
good luck guys jerry good luck man
and there you have it the players are
getting set
and we are also going to get set so
we're going to come back in just a
moment
and with the first uh games of the night
the third
place match between rustic and the anime
man
we will see you in a few moments
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and we are back and uh we are ready
for our match between restage and the
anime man to begin
uh somebody's gonna walk away with an
extra
four hundred dollars in their pocket and
they're also going to walk away with
bragging rights
right uh jt what do you think i mean you
know
joey's your student but you've also had
a few days of watching russiage do his
thing i mean
is this gonna be all right so
so basically this is konoha right here
okay and i am kakashi sensei and
rustage even though not my student he's
lee and we have
sasuke as the anime man and they're
fighting off it didn't happen in the
anime
but it's going to happen here and you're
going to watch this top
10 anime fight right now i haven't then
who am i who am i in that
thing like but because i did i did a
video where i became a saiyan
and i screamed and i and i reached like
level 9000 or something
so oh you weren't over 9000
i did good with whatever i was supposed
to do with the saiyan level
i see yeah i was about to say i had to
bring danny back on camera so that we
could see him pretend to understand
i was going to say i i literally set a
bet with myself how soon does it before
charlie
pushes the anime references to the point
where i feel awkward
and and you literally did it in under 30
seconds so
lucky for me the uh the games have just
begun
and uh no i'm kidding this is gonna be a
lot of fun i can't wait to combine
our chess instruction with anime
references and all that
oh yeah awesome and the movies are
coming out on the board and um
you know i think it'd be kind of fun to
go ahead and listen into russia's first
thing just to get his opening ideas
let's do it um i [ __ ] up immediately i
did it on the wrong side
he already is saying he made a mistake
all right [ __ ] it i've
i i've i meant to do it on this side i
did it on this side because i was
practicing it as black
i was practicing it as black and i did
it on the wrong side okay
i'm sure this is still a thing i'm
actually sure this is still like a thing
that people do
so i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna think
he did on the wrong side but
it's okay he hasn't messed up yet
this is wait he hasn't messed up can
they hear me i'm sorry don't over speak
in the crowd hear me
for breaking the fourth wall yeah i i
messed up immediately
yeah go ahead danny let's let's actually
take a look at this
well it's interesting because
he's not wrong that he that he messed up
so to speak right he's literally playing
a king's indian attack
you know on on the queen side here
charlie right i mean normally
if you change all these moves and it's a
knight on f3 with a pawn on d3 and that
bishop is being kettling
white has chances to do this with the
pawn chain and head toward the king side
now you're in kind of an awkward spot
because this is a little bit weird
to do this with the bishop pinning the
knight it makes you start wondering
if there's going to be immediate
immediate consequences and tactics here
if the knight comes into e4 but yeah
we'll see
right right and even moves like um
capturing on
d4 first make a lot of sense but here
we might even see some awkward kind of
like
kali zukrator kind of setup
maybe we have to see you it could i mean
sometimes for the for those tuning in
sometimes the move knight to c3 on move
one is actually designed from a
practical
point of view as a weapon because your
intention is to play
a center pawn on the next move that
transposes into the opening you want so
you play it purely for psychological
reasons
confuse them maybe gain time on the
clock e5 can be met by e4
and then maybe you play a vienna game or
if they play c5
you play e4 and go into a closed
sicilian grand prix
or if they play d5 you can even play d4
and go into a verisoft now this is
complicated transposition stuff but i
think it's important for the viewers to
understand it's not that knight c3 is a
bad move
necessarily it's just that trying to
play this idea with it being keto
is not going to have the the ultimate
outcome that rusted wants
that's all well and you know an
interesting thing emerges from that
right maybe the
accidental incorrect move order is
having an effect psychologically on the
anime man
so maybe we'll listen into him and see
uh if that's the case
what wow what an interesting opening
all right i'm gonna castle just
preemptively
oh he caught on the queen's side oh [ __ ]
okay
oh man that's a really good castle too
because he's really [ __ ]
strengthened this up um very
complimentary
wow
but i like the transition he was playing
really fast in his previous games
and now he's taking his time maybe it's
the soothing music
maybe
soothing music always slows me down i
can try and aim for a double
fork on his two roxy and he doesn't
identifying the fort on f2
so i can just slide in great to be proud
of your student right there
oh yeah oh yeah
you know and i've left these two
diagonals open
for my queen and bishop to come out just
in case
ah see
but he won't take that because my bishop
is ready to go
so
yep some patience here and what's very
interesting about this position is that
normally for beginners they tend to
release attention very early and they
try to take take take
and here they're just keeping the
tension in the center so it shows a lot
of class and a lot of patience
and that they're actually thinking about
the position
i agree charlie and and even if it's not
necessarily the best move uh for example
to play
knight g4 here on move seven right to go
for the fork
the fact that they're recognizing the
potential for the tactic is is really
good and then the prestige goes out of
his way
to defend it right they're not being
neglectful of their opponent's threats
and
there's there's so many other ways you
could do things i mean you could develop
a knight
to try to defend the pawn or do other
things but i agree that it shows that
they're
they're really being very cognizant of
their opponent's plans in this game i
mean nobody
nobody is making massive wonders they're
both looking for tactics
it's a good uh good sign and the clocks
are very even at this point
and restage is doing his typical uh
he plays he's he he plays a lot with the
arrows
pretty much every time he makes a move
he's
automatically going back to drawing more
possibilities on his board and and let's
listen in because he he likes to run
through a lot of possibilities before
settling on a
on a decision his weakest piece
i think it served him well so far
you can see his eyes shifting
i think i blocked off my queen here
by doing that which is annoying
maybe i shouldn't have moved that like
that won't be one okay
okay fella he's he can't come in for
that again because of this
but if he goes in there he he's
threatening that and i can't
move this but again he can't do that so
he's threatening my
is that right hold up i'll take it
wait hold up is it free uh double check
he's not attacking he's not defending it
with anything
and when i move this his bishop doesn't
get any new lines so i'll take it
okay so exchanges it's time
and he found he found the free piece it
was a free piece on e4 and he just
took the free piece it was there and you
know my phrase
if it's free it's for me
it's that doesn't necessarily apply to
all things in life
right right right right right what i'm
with but i'm with you um
yeah 94 uh black probably should have
played that move earlier when the knight
was still pinned to the king right
um so now rustage is up a piece
and although again like
just knowing you know the level of
players we have here there's a lot to
the game left so we'll see how rustage
deals with
the anime man coming out now developing
the bishop with a threat but
looking good for russia so far i agree
what's really interesting i think in
this position
is what happens after knight g3
um and then the bishop moves somewhere
where
i found it knight g3 yep bishop move
somewhere and then we can capture on e5
well i wonder if russia sees that
because the rook has been on the same
line as the queen for a while
um and you know jt we we see this with
students a lot where sometimes when
you've had
the possibility of taking something for
so long it just sort of
you just forget it and it just leaves
your brain not to you should be
rechecking tactics
rechecking captures on every single move
no matter what level of chess you're at
and that's that's a trouble move
right there that does not it does not
recheck what the knight was doing
oh boy uh rustage is maybe gonna have
more than just a slight advantage let's
just send into anime man and see if he
realizes
now this bishop is on it's like yeah
[ __ ]
okay yeah oh that was not a good move
that was not a good [ __ ] move dog
that was a [ __ ] move dog
god damn that was not a good move
not a good move it's a good move
bill i should have moved i should i
don't know why i didn't see the bishop
there
um
i'm telling you man rust is [ __ ] big
brain mode right now
[ __ ] man so identifying identifying
he's in a tough spot yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah and here comes the first
check on the board though right
i mean this is okay he quickly responds
this is good
the truth is if white recognized the
potential of the attack
even taking e5 to unleash the bishop on
the king is
probably worth the sacrifice at this
point although
i wouldn't be surprised if russia just
brings the knight back to safety
so the biggest issue and again if i was
talking about why why did he miss
on bishop f5 the fact that the knight
was attacking the bishop it's because
he played that move to attack a piece
and when that piece left like sometimes
when you're the aggressor in early
stages of chess understanding you forget
that the counterbalance of chess that
works all the time
is that your opponent's threats are just
as important as your own
more important right and that's
different than every other board game i
know it sounds like i'm pointing out the
obvious but it really
is a different psychology than other
board games which shouldn't be compared
to
you know whoa i'm sorry guys
what was that he did it
let's see and that's an example of what
i was just talking about
he what he was only thinking about his
threats he wasn't thinking about where
his opponent's pieces were
oh my gosh and let's see i would love to
listen
to you i did that so quickly he just
took my queen
i should have paused i should have
paused and thought why did he do that
yeah this is uh another queen blunder
from daniel rustage
i know they're down and the animals of
history is the queen is a terrible peace
silly chess game but it doesn't mean you
should move it that fast
stupid i should have moved my horse
instead
he's done that to pop these squares i
guess yeah yes
and i think losing the queen uh ruin
the morale yeah but
not wanting to talk over him does he
realize though that
because he's picked up some extra
material material earlier on
maybe it's not the worst thing
i mean obviously you don't want to just
give your stuff away but is he really
all that worse off it's crazy because
he's not
actually this is a great example i mean
and the evaluation of the computer tells
you that
that he actually has currently a rook
and
two minor pieces for the queen so
despite when you win two pieces for free
right
despite blundering the queen russet just
not actually losing it's more the
psychological blow of being a beginner
player
to lose the queen to such an obvious
blunder makes you
you know it's things a little bit but um
but if he takes on e5 here especially if
he keeps the dark square bishop jt what
do you think
do you think he realizes the potential
of that bishop and he's going to take
with a knight
or do you think he or do you think maybe
he doesn't appreciate how important this
beast is here
i i think that he will understand that
that maybe the f3 knight really doesn't
have
too much of a future and the attack on
the king might uh
be good so maybe taking with the knight
on f3
uh and taking on e5 and then the pawn
captures and bishop captures and
the black king is in a world of trouble
so i actually think he is going to find
it
because he was capable of finding a lot
of great moves during his last game
okay it's hard i think that uh
the less experienced you are at chess
the more you rely on the heavy major
pieces right the pieces that are all
powerful
that can do you know super saiyan things
look at me making an anime reference
okay oh my god i'm so cute now
um but but look at no but they don't
maybe always appreciate the ability to
coordinate we're like
we always say there's a tipping point
with students where they they can now
outplay the queen with two rooks they
don't prefer the queen versus the two
rooks right
and i think it's hard because he clearly
didn't appreciate there with that move
c3
what his potential was of all of these
pieces on the e5 square we can already
see that
dania i'm gonna give you three and a
half out of seven dragon balls for that
reference that was pretty
really is that is that a good thing yeah
um
three i've had a seven yeah it's half
half the dragon balls
okay um so but you know what i'm saying
jt i mean the thing is like as
a aspiring player it takes experience
where before you can
outmaneuver and out coordinate an
opponent versus just flexing
on the easy to move pieces that's why i
just had a lesson with hoftor the you
know the strong world's strongest man
the mountain
and his preference to the rook over the
knight bishop was very clear
because that's how it feels as a you
know when you're learning the game
right so it's dangerous here
i i i would say that despite the eval
bar and despite
rustage being better i'm going to make a
bold prediction that
the anime man wins this game
and that pawn has now moved forward
undefending
one of his extra pieces tonight
this is one of the it's good
to say it's not just psychological that
you need the queen it's that they they
don't have the experience to outmaneuver
not coordinate so that's why i made that
statement of course blunders can happen
for anyone but
anyway sorry go ahead so i think
that the anime man won't see this
because it was really hard for
because he thought it was defended the
last move and
he doesn't look at that anymore so
that's what happened in his previous
games
so if he got better he'll see that the
knight is now hanging
yeah and let me let's listen in and see
if we can hear that he notices or not
and
and he's not throwing tonight he's not
holding the piece that
wins him material
yeah i should turn the knife
he's got a little bit of extra time on
his clock to protect the night rather
not threaten it
and he mentions threatening the night
but i mean the night's free
yeah the night is free
i think you'll notice that this move
you'll notice that there's nothing
oh actually i just found a really
sweet pin that i should probably try and
do
next move if i move this night here and
take this knight
then i can swing in here and that's a he
found it he founded rocks
he found the free piece really nice
trade and more
yep you know what i think i'm going to
still didn't stop it
now he's probably going to move this
rock down
or he's going to see that i'm going to
move to f2 next
reaction to that if he realizes now yeah
let's uh let's see if we can switch over
to rustic
yeah he's very focused on his opponent's
threats now because he's so
psychologically burdened by the queen
blender and i think that was already
happening
i don't know why i didn't take it before
he could have done that i don't know why
i didn't move my
night earlier he could have done that
for so long
um i don't want him to pincer my guys
the rest is only with two minutes now
and i just can't take that though
so oh that's the only thing protecting
that that's a free bishop this is
what the anime man saw do that
and again it's the queen's ability
psychologically and for players of this
ability
to really flex and uh i'm not i'm not
surprised the direction this game is
going
restitch may not see that that bishop is
falling
yeah maybe the attention somewhere else
maybe he's just trying to pile up
pressure on f2
he's doing that then i'm going to move
him apparently so is the inner idea
what's he threatening he's three he's
attacking the pawn as well there
so he takes i take and then he does that
uh this one at least delay him because i
put him in check on the checker whether
it's useful or not i don't know i
i wouldn't take that pawn i would just
say hey that pawn is
blocking the h foul and i'ma just leave
that alone
thank you and he does and he does
that's a great point well that wishful
thinking seems like it paid off right
mm-hmm
i i mean this is this is kind of
you know the direction a game will go
with it with a big piece versus
little pieces and white was white was
still totally winning despite the queen
loss earlier but really not surprised
that uh this is where it's heading and
it would take a blunder in return uh the
anime man joey would have to return the
favor here
and make some sort of massive blunder of
his lady i believe in order for this
game to go back the other way
um and i just don't expect that i think
he's going to see your idea jt
i think he's going to take on e2 and and
are you are you going to talk about
i think he's going to take on f2 okay
because he's been trying to do that all
game and i don't see the reason why he
wouldn't do it right now because he's
focused on this one plan
right okay well i mean this is
this is hard and you know the sign that
the sign that rustage went for that
h-pawn
kind of kind of thrusting over there was
this oh oh
that gives it gives white some life um
it just shows that i think rustage like
was getting kind of desperate after the
queen was lost and didn't realize the
full potential of his pieces
but we'll see i mean there's still
there's still life here right there's
still there's enough material on the
board that anything could happen
right and it gets quite scary in the
middle game because you don't really
know what
to do see i'd like that move c4 again if
we have to forget the fact that we know
the bishop is hanging oh we can't forget
it
[Laughter]
instantly i was gonna i was gonna say
that bishop's been now been hanging for
you know five moves so we have to assume
maybe anime man doesn't see it i was
wrong
so can we see what the enemy man is
thinking because yeah let's do it
absolutely
what are you gonna do rust
he's sacrificing the music
his best move is to move the rock up
here because he knows i can't
take this knight because this pawn is
here oh
okay oh nice actually he
protected it wow that was a really good
move
and rusted that's not 30 seconds the
enemy man has three minutes
um that's huge but uh joey can force
another exchange here can't he
okay i think i might just
oh that's what i was wondering what
happened i think i'm just retreating
sorry
i'm a little bit ahead of the stream
delay because i'm watching it
my oh [ __ ] i did not
[ __ ] see that dog commentator's curse
no that's not on me that's not what i'm
making about
my television delay which is good for
all fair players
[ __ ] me i did not see that but actually
i did not feel this might be very
interesting because there are a lot of
dark squares that are very weak
and you have the dark square bishop it's
true
it's true again it's right back but like
i said i think it would take a queen
sack i said it would take a blunder of
the lady
for russia to come back and that's what
happens and
it is it is still unclear but now
now i'm just going to go back to
favoring the major pieces i mean even
from a practical point of view
black has a good center and a very very
nice dark sport bishop
at this level the brooks are just
uh now the rook is trapped rustic
rustage has
some new life but not a lot of time
to spend on it yep no good point we
forgot about that
let's listen in and see if he oh boy
this is going to get interesting for
sure let's listen in threaten that
fair enough still just going to take um
and there is a double attack on the
board
oh didn't see it
that's a trade it is still trapped
i don't have any time to think if the
trade is good yeah
it probably isn't oh no my rook's stuck
it's my punch
i can't go there oops
whoops he's coming under 10 seconds
already made a move just in time
to check there's a check lots of things
my work is completely stuck
the rook can't move
yes
that's good actually and on sticks my
room
thank you thank you for that maybe i
should have moved the other way
nope it unsticks my rook but i still
[ __ ] lose it
ah i thought i had a comeback there but
i didn't
and i i it's because i was making all my
moves quickly because i was running out
of time
he has to be careful the pastor very
nice identifying the pastor
all right he does have to pass her
though i mean
okay stranger things have happened
then uh okay never mind never mind he's
giving up the past oh yeah so he could
just take it
no i forget that the king can actually
touch his gun over at king upon him
with joey so i think this is an easy win
for him
really yes because i will just timeout
okay wrestle's realizing he has to move
fast he is building time on his clock
and
he's also maybe realizing he needs to
escort that
on but it's gonna be too little
yeah just a little bit yep and we have
also gone over queen and king checkmate
so i think
yeah it seems like a coach seems like a
coach did his due diligence there
i love that i mean i don't i'm hoping
you're not jinxing yourself and
youtube setting up a stalemate here but
you oh there we go
there you go that makes it easy and
promotes with checkmates so one game
in the books anime man takes the first
game of the match
he's stoked and the second game will
start right away russage will be in a
must-win situation
because all the anime man needs is a
draw
out of the next game at the very least
to clinch third place
in tournament arc
i i you know i said when i came on in
our pre-show that all the matches up to
this point were 2-0
in favor of what seemed to be kind of
the clearly stronger player in hindsight
not taking anything away from those who
lost but
i have a feeling this might be different
i think the rustage might get the w here
and we might have our first
we might have our first 1-1 tie uh you
know the format similar to
the pog champs uh which an event that
happened
in june and is preparing to happen again
um
i don't know i think rustage really let
that one get away
something about the way they played
makes me think russets is the stronger
player but let some things
go away so we'll see we'll see okay at
this level you know anything can happen
and i think that that's the excitement
and he's playing really good moves the
enemy man playing good moves quickly
rustage now has the opening he intended
to get the first time by the way
instead of the reverse right well you
know russia talked about how he felt
like he plays
better as black and whenever i went to
review his games a few weeks ago before
his coaching session he
he seemed like he does do better as
black so let's see if this is
translating into some confidence
for him to get black in the second game
yep
uh
if that's not protected by anything but
the queen
if i can like if i can put another
attacker on that square
to attack that square i would be happy
be happy boy um
oh it's defended by this okay never mind
i'm not gonna do that then
i always blunder early so i'm with my
queen so i just moved rook there
no that unprotects the pawn it doesn't i
got it with the king but it's still
annoying
and i do like all the moves that both
players are playing they're playing in
the center
they have the two knights two bishops
out
should have done that last message not
talking as much in the
losing
i need to focus i'm on like
self-destructive mode right now because
i
i um
blundered really badly
so he's uh he's he's checking in on
himself he's reminding himself to slow
down just need to think about things now
i would like to see what joey's thinking
here
yeah let's uh let's switch off and let's
do the enemy man for a second
he's either going to take with the horse
or the pawn here
oh okay he took it with the pawn that's
okay
then i'll take with the horse and now he
has to take with the horse and then we
tried queens
queen trade queen trade hype
joey's happy about that yeah you know
what rust let's make this game
interesting dude
let's make this game interesting
and this this might be our first game
that goes
into the tie break let's see i'm hyped
uh that's a bad move there
that's not something i did call the
tiebreak i'm sorry
that's like a commentator's curse there
again
well i i just i don't know i feel like
i feel like just looking at the bracket
there's no way we're not going to get at
least a match that's 1-1 and we head to
a tie break and i think rustage is
not taking anywhere from your students
right and and we all love joey the anime
man but i just feel like russ is just
the stronger player right now i just
really do and i think that
that game got away from him
psychologically with that queen blunder
but
um well look in the second game maybe
you take away his queen
he can't blunder it right can't blunder
anymore
equally now we're good now we're good
now restage can really play
right and actually we have done some
bullet practice
for joey so he's used to the bullet
format which is 1-0
so i think the 3-0 section might be in
his favor
that's interesting that's interesting i
i mean that's a
as a coach who's working with guys for
paw champs right now working with fenton
hand easy with aces and half tour and
some others
i haven't thought a lot about that
putting them in a tiebreaker scenario
but that's an interesting tip i might
think about that just in case um because
it might pay off
and it begs the question has rustage
practiced any fast time controls
right i'm gonna i'm gonna guess
no i mean based on how we managed his
time in the end of that last game guys
after after the anime and blunder's
queen back if if joey
sorry if if rostage had had more time on
his clock he might have been okay but i
feel like rustage is
a little bit of a slower player so far
from what i've seen
he likes to calculate everything he
likes his arrows he likes highlighting
squares
and the enemy man is just like i just
want to have fun let's just do this
he also likes to have alexa likes to
have a fan blowing in his
in his hair we should definitely get a
zoom in on that i think maybe that's a
requirement from his hair product
sponsors
to get that to get that ocean breeze
going you know
oh man so i want to ask you guys about
the current position so
so obviously the eval is saying black is
doing really well here
maybe you can point out a couple of the
reasons why
well uh jt why don't you go first sure
um so right now black is controlling the
only open file
right and they do have the two bishops
and a beautiful square for that
uh light squared bishop on c8 is to go
to e6 and control very long diagonal
from a2
all the way to g8 also the dark square
bishop it's already on
probably the best square on the board
for the bishop to be on which is g7
cutting the board in half
on the dark diagonal his knights have
easy outposts and we talked
about that before where the ponzi really
can't attack them and the other rook
has easy access maybe we can double the
rook and on the default and really
control even more
or maybe there could be on the c file
and we can play c5 for the pawn break
i was going to say you went full
coaching mode there you forgot to point
out the most obvious reason black is
winning is he's up two pieces
watch that but i love that so that was
that was like the best like clipable
moment ever i'm like sitting here like
that's great but also black's up two
pieces
and so yes the open file is great and i
think that actually in hindsight that
last move knight takes h2
gives back one of the pieces but but
doesn't change that black is winning
he probably could have moved his knight
instead and and maybe
did a double attack on the bishop in the
night on c3 but either way great great
stuff great coaching i love it i love it
and i was going to say that really the
most fundamental thing here is that
black won a couple pieces earlier and
without a blunder to come back one of
the things that makes chess different
than other games for
players that are new is that in theory
if you just do your job once you're up
that kind of material
you should win every chess game you play
right it's not like other sports where
you see great comebacks of teams down by
25 points
because they don't also get penalized
with less men
and a higher rim to shoot at right they
always have a chance
it's always equal footing and chess if
black does his job here
there shouldn't be a chance for life
like just don't blunder your own book
get your pieces involved and you have
more of them you know so that's just
i think it's the right psychology to put
yourself in with your own material just
play simple chess don't let your
opponent's threats win the day
well the anime man has to be in problem
solving mode right now
and maybe we can even spectate in and
catch him
you know guessing about what might
happen in a tiebreak situation
oh
oh that was a really good move
[ __ ] man
well i can still threaten your rook
oh actually hold on
eight minutes on the clock he has a lot
of time he can spend here
just to make sure he's not making
symptoms that's fine he won't take that
because then i'll just take it
so i've got to protect this pawn
wow putting pressure on the pin piece
you guys know what that is so use this
bishop to threaten
oh actually [ __ ] yeah see what he's
doing there a little bit of
pp on the peepee that's right
oh
and rustage is basically making joey's
moves for him
by playing some forcing chests and then
i can just take with the king
but it should be okay and then we trade
pieces but he's technically still ahead
in pieces so it's more of an advantage
for him unless he's going to move this
rook back
make some trades understanding that he
is down
in this scenario yeah yeah he can
identify that he's in a tough
spot um but he
he's not giving up no and rustage is not
putting it away yet i mean even though
that last move
instead of trading on g2 first black
could have
made this move knight g4 check i saw
someone in twitch chat
saying that earlier and the knight could
have come to g4 shack for a while
so you're right um twitch chat and that
that might cost rustage because doing so
would have been like a free move when
you can get a check
that brings another piece into the game
a lot of times that's a good idea
right and now look yes rustage is still
winning he's still up a piece
but if you're watching that eval bar and
that number from a few moves ago
this is no longer the nearly plus
double digit advantage for black this
this could get messy
so jt did you you've been sharing all
these coaching things you did with joey
the anime man
did you guys talk about the right
psychology when you're losing right a
lot of coaches focus on winning
right how to convert which is good
because you want your students to be
able to control what they can control
which is win winning positions and as a
coach i always worked on that control
where you could control
which is when you're winning you win you
can't always control that you sit down
from someone who just kicks your ass
because they're better let's just put it
bluntly right
but but i wonder like what is it did you
talk any psychology like hey
you know how do you deal with it how do
you deal with a tough situation right
and so
actually that's what i kind of put into
my uh the bullet
portion of that um i said there are
going to be some times where it's out of
your control
and you just need to play the best moves
that are on the board now don't worry
about what you've lost don't try to get
that material back
find if you see a tactic great but
don't force don't don't try to force
your hand if you don't need to just
say okay what do i have now what can i
do now and go from there
yeah it's it's actually really good
advice to have short term memory loss
as a coach like working with people to
get them to focus on the position in the
now because very often
like we saw that game with rustage last
game yes he blundered but he was
actually still winning if he could
remove his emotion and focus on the now
right
very often the first mistake you make in
chess is not the move that's losing you
the game
it's the mistakes that follow and um
that's good advice he's another fork he
finds he's quick
quick oh my gosh and he's right back in
it i was giving the psychology advice i
didn't even i wasn't looking what's in
front of me
is that the opposite of the
commentator's curse is a commentator's
blessing let's listen in on wrestling
now we can just take my goddamn rook
that's so annoying and that was never an
option anyway because he would just take
it
i take the bishop
oh no i could have a bishop's better i
think fish is better
i could just take his knight but i think
taking the bishop was better
he's got a time disadvantage but there's
still plenty of time
you know especially with the gameplay
yeah just be very careful not to take
that pawn on e5
playing f6 wow
nothing protecting that
in a way i kind of like that he draws
arrows after making the move so he
remembers why he did it
crazy move dude i can just move my pawn
up
to protect it yeah
i think our wrestling with his giga uh
definitely teaching us something right
now
and you know i wanna i want you guys to
illustrate something because i think
this is something that when i discovered
it the first time i was blown away by it
this this bishop and pawn unit
on g and h files it's like almost
indestructible
right yeah yeah and one of the big
things is it's an anchor
so they protect each other the pawn
moves forward to attack to attack slash
protect his own piece
and the bishop moves backward to protect
slash attack his own pawn so when you
can build things around an
anchor like that you have you have
something you know that's that's sort of
a focal point
you know um to to bring pieces to
if if black were an advanced player here
this is totally unclear position the
bishop can come to e5 would check
the knight could get involved with
something like knight to e6 and also
help attack the king
so and c3's hanging this is
this this game is could go either way i
have zero clues to make a prediction now
i thought we'd have a tie tie
a tie tie tie tie one one um i'mma be a
little tight
after this match um but uh no i don't
know what's gonna happen here this is
this is
wild
i would love to listen into the anime
man and see what he's calculating
because this is actually a very
rough position for him he just came back
yes he's still in comeback mode you know
i would love to know that it's been a
roller coaster let's listen
i know you don't yeah that's what i
thought
that's okay though oh let's check
that's okay let's take that then you'll
probably just take this
that's fine too
wow what a strong move
but now i can promote
he's already talking about promotion but
you know you need to coordinate in order
to do that right three pawns
on this side he's on the other 96 and
i've still got my trading
and i'm [ __ ] three minutes ahead
four minutes ahead he's happy about the
time advantage
yeah come on you know you want to take
it
if you're not going to take it i'm going
to take this pawn and
with promote bishop here this is bishops
are in a really weird position now where
they're kind of
too far on this end of the map that they
can't really protect the pawns on this
side
that's what i thought it was going to do
okay and then i'll just take this
and now his bishop's in danger again
identifying that the bishop on e6 is
hanging and if this
pawn decides to like start sliding in
then i can just move the
rook back joey's looking at all these
sequences
it's impressive he's playing very
resilient
okay threaten this bishop again there's
a pin
see if joey realizes the giga brain
okay uh oh [ __ ]
oh i'm just gonna take that then stop
promoting
okay interesting choice he's up a piece
but just don't be too fast with those
pawns i need a friend
this pawn oh he can catch it oh king f4
was slightly pretty much
scurred oh wow
so wild here
all right first of all joey does a great
job giving insight into his thought
process
we should just say that um and what's
funny is actually
uh rustage missed the wind the best
thing to do when the rook was actually
pinned was to just leave it frozen
and start pushing the h-pawn right away
and then black would have been winning
by force
now i i don't know what's going to
happen
it if black makes the right move here to
bring up the king first
then black is still winning but if he
pushes the pawn it's going to be a draw
i think
yes oh wow
rustage just found that move minnie
davaretsky
minnie jimmy man i worked with mark
divoretsky and and by the way
even more props to rustige because he
found that move with little time on the
clock
um i know it's a choice between our
commentary here and listening in there
but i i'm
curious what his thought process would
have been there but it's been look at
his technique here he clearly recognized
everyone
that the bishop was perfect where it was
yes that's just
huge covering the promotion square for
both of them
yep that he didn't need to do anything
and
now short of some horrible blunder it's
an easy win you could put the bishop on
a8 which might be something he does to
sort of feel warm and cozy
right just run away in theory oh okay he
goes there that's
that's the wrong way to do it now you're
inviting the king up with tempe
but yeah okay great idea nice
look at the patience here by rustage
guys we're gonna have a one-on-one time
wow let's listen in to russia as he
figures out how to wrap this up
yeah but we have to be careful that
h-pawn is a little bit close that h6
pawn
so if you get straight off i have way
less time to work with than he does
so in a position like this he's he's in
a better position he wins the race
yep have to take that he can't go down
like that
but i can still just
block it please resign jerry
i'm really asking joey to resign
maybe he's not confident yeah
i mean i'm gonna start trying to push
this guy over to the corner
i don't know how to do it with a bishop
moving the bishop away is not ideal
needs to use the queen
there we go nice
limit the space that the king has to
travel
that's good all right so he's now he's
stuck here
i have to find a way to block him off
or he can't do anything
this is intense he's only got a minute
and a half do
this oh no no because then he'll get a
queen i could do this
and then move my queen down hold up hold
on if i move here and then move my queen
down would that be a checkmate
not much he could do about that not
drops
joey offers a drop checkmate if i
declines
would that be a checkmate hold up let me
double check if i move my queen here
he wouldn't be able to take it he
wouldn't be able to move wow
and let's uh let's listen as he
yeah thank god wow oh no now we've got
to go to the three minute game
the relief and yes you're right you now
have to play 3-0
there is no increment to see by the way
no no rest for the weary
whoever's moderating our match behind
the scenes way to go that is a quick
start
we didn't even have a chance to to
debrief that
what great technique by the way wow from
rustage
um in the end right i mean
all of those games could be could be
totally wild with a lot of back and
forth but
and i guys i know it's a weird thing
normally i'm full of commentators curse
but i feel like i've been
i've been i've had a pretty good ear of
the grindstone with this one
i feel like i've had a good feel for
what's gonna happen
and it's a one-one tie
rusted just back on the white pieces and
okay we gotta wait to see what happens
out of the opening here
he did go back to his knight c3 king's
indian attack which is a little awkward
right i think just here i think he's
gonna castle and he's just gonna be fine
yep great great you know
get all your pieces active this is what
we talked about yeah
well objectively charlie black is just
doing great here i mean like this is why
you don't play
a king's indian attack with knight to c3
and bishop oh
oh he didn't he made the same mistake no
that's okay
but it's being denied the e4 was better
i think c5 and then d4
okay well fine never mind
yeah he's losing himself a little bit
which is again it's an interesting
question like is there
is there a hangover from the last loss
right he maybe feels like he had the
match and let it go
and and now he's kind of lost himself a
little bit
oh oh my gosh rustage no
no no it's protected by this
i blunted so badly of course i did i
didn't have time to think i have three
minutes
joey must be stoked here as well
that's not even a trade is it wow i'm
speechless
it's good okay
this is going to be lost by timeout and
he'll win let me just move quickly
and not think about it as much
he's just decided he's gonna move
quickly and he's gonna keep fighting
now if they draw and then i'm still not
moving quickly they will play another
game
okay
wow strong moves really strong moves
seriously um
i'm so happy i played that bullet
session with him
i had a free rook but he didn't see it
up
a little too quickly there that's fine
because i'm stupid
i can't take because of that whoops i
don't know
it's too fast
when it comes to speed dude he's got me
he's got me good
how can he do these things so fast
this tune is killing me on speed he is
killing him and
uh my goodness the anime man must be
feeling
pretty hot right now he he's got
all the material
am i responding to that or
are you still overwhelmed
oh no why did i do that that was a bad
move that was a bad move i should have
moved the rock
oh i should have moved the rook [ __ ]
in my [ __ ]
oh my goodness
this is insane this is absolutely insane
they're just giving each other gif this
is it's like christmas
but i think regardless of the board uh
jt's training and bullet paid off
because look at the clock
oh yeah there's a beautiful move to
clean this up oh
i just want him to create some luft
please um
um um um only thing these make so many
things let me think
let me think let me think careful about
that back rank mate
there you go protecting your king
so it can escape yeah that was huge
especially at this level oh my gosh 20
seconds left for restage
oh you son of a [ __ ] you son of a [ __ ]
i think we're gonna stay here
okay now rookie two would have been cool
to just get those rooks off the board
right uh
[ __ ] okay
rustic not realizing you could have
taken that
and restage is feeling it it's on it's
he's going to win on time
and let's listen in as uh
[Music]
let's go third place baby
trash taste top three let's
[ __ ] go i didn't let my boys down
wow i didn't let my boys down
boys i did it he did it he did it for
the trash chase top three there it is
anime man wins third place amazing
amazing the happiness of his coach is
is felt very above me but seriously that
was that was great from all around and i
think that rustage clearly
uh didn't have us didn't have the same
level of comfort in the blitz because
regardless of what happened on the board
and even on the board in the end the
enemy
man is is totally winning here right but
regardless of that
the clock the clock situation is a
massive difference so i'll give a shout
out to you
uh jt charlie whatever we're calling you
i guess jt for japanese tutorials
yep yep that's my date uh i'd love to
show these players this last game if we
can so let's get them
let's get them on the broadcast we'll
take a quick break and when we come back
we will have the anime man
and rustage stay tuned
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and we're back with the players wow guys
i just want to say that was
so exciting the first tie break we've
seen in the entire
tournament i mean wow i'm exhausted how
about you
i i think i blunted my queen three times
i did i blotted my queen three times
uh and it will forever haunt me to this
day
i don't think i'll ever stop i hate i
hate queens you know what queen victoria
[ __ ]
worst terrible uh no i'm just
blind and especially in that blitz game
i was trying to move as fast as possible
because in the blitz game i was just
under the impression that it's gonna be
really difficult to get the
checkmate so i'm gonna just try and win
on time so i just started moving moves
really
quick and i blunted my queen so and then
joey what a time anyway so
nah i'm honestly just happy that we got
to even show a blitz game like i was
i was really worried that we wouldn't
even be able to show a blitz game in
this tournament but
yeah i caught it i said it would happen
um yeah i think i did too like earlier
on i said i really hope we go into a
blitz game because that would be so high
and it was well rusted did you play any
blitz in preparation for that because
jt was talking about in some of his
training with with uh joey here um that
they actually did practice some bullet
blitz did you have any time to play the
faster time controls or
or not okay i i have not played anything
actually i
that's a lie i did play like a one
minute game once
and i kind of just moved my pieces
randomly and won by timeout
okay uh but yeah i did i didn't i didn't
get any blitz practice which is
my burden i didn't practice hard enough
and jerry deserved that win
no and you're you're very humble about
it and yeah i mean it was great it was
great i was just asking because i think
it's a good sign that there's
you know opportunities to to work on
that right because i think you clearly
struggled a little bit more with the
time management right you felt that you
were
you were down on the clock in almost
every game right yeah i was always down
on
i'm really bad because i i try and think
things if i don't think things through
then i blunder my queen
it's annoying that i blunted my queen in
the first game as well because i felt
like i was
winning until i did you were for sure
yeah well danny maybe you want to take
us through that and show some of those
moments where the advantages
started to slip so just before he does
does that um uh i actually threw so that
we could get trash taste pos
top three because i knew i didn't like
that
i just wanted to do it for the fans you
know the audience that loves trash cans
that's the reason why the check is in
the mail right joey
yeah yeah so rustage can you see um
see the position on the board here yes
yes so you were doing great
in fact you were up two pieces um and we
we had been highlighting on on the uh
on the show at the time that a lot of
common mistakes at this level are
we make an attacking move and it's
different than other board games with
chess because
to win monopoly your goal is to focus on
your plan
roll your dice and focus on your plan
it's chess really does challenge that
where
everything that your opponent is doing
is equal to you so when they take you
for example your first instinct is well
i'm gonna have to take back
right every other time this has happened
i thought it through
and i was and it's the one time i didn't
be like why did he do that
right okay that's that's great and i and
i think um
so what's funny is you you said that um
were you winning before the queen this
is a rare case where i'm going to show
you that
because you had won two pieces and
actually the rook
you were actually still technically
winning even after the queen i think
that you got
a little bit psychologically tilted you
decided to rush the h-pawn
which made sense because you were like
well i got to go after his king right
that was your mindset
yeah but but you're beast here on b2 the
beast of a bishop if you had seen him
yeah if you had if you had kept this guy
opening up you know if we
if you had found more ways to get this
guy involved i
blocked him because i panicked i'm sorry
i just
i don't have a strong enough mental for
chess because
i i make a move like losing my queen and
then i immediately
get into self-destruct mode and i just
kind of want to
like get underneath blankets and cry for
the next few hours
no that's how chess players feel too man
no don't don't sell yourself short
that's a normal
thing but we were literally talking
about the show i said i think that
rustage
lost his queen and kind of lost himself
along the way because you didn't realize
your position was actually still
pretty good and that's a hard thing to
recover from but okay joey not taking
anything i mean you you also played
fantastically and i think that
as it went on you showed in some ways
that your work with charlie paid off
you felt like you were the more
practical player in some ways you were
you were making sure you played fast up
on the clock and
let me ask you joey was that part of
your goal was just like hey
i'm gonna make sure i'm up on time in
every game oh yeah definitely because i
think
especially with like the two games i've
seen rusty playing like he he definitely
does like to
sink things through and that's that's
just that just leaves me more of an
opportunity to at least get up on time
to put even more pressure on him and
with that like b2 bishop as well i saw
that that b2 bishop was trapped the
entire time
so i was like okay if i'm going to take
advantage of him in any way
then i have to make sure that that b2
bishop never comes out
and uh joey had some huge brain moves he
was so smart
like his brain is on another level he
opened it
we're both equal we're both equal i
think we played a really equal match
yeah i'm going to agree and um guys i
i just realized that that this is this
is it this is the last time we're gonna
have you on the show
i mean i i've gotten so used to seeing
you every day and now
i know it's over but i i you know you
guys uh
not only obviously uh make steady
content on youtube
but you also both stream regularly on
twitch
so uh the people watching the show right
now can
keep uh keep an eye on both of you right
i mean
yeah so any any final thoughts joey
let's start with you uh what was
tournament art like and um
and and you know are we gonna see you
playing chess
um in maybe a future event
um yeah i mean if if you guys decide to
do set up a tournament
arc part 2 then yeah definitely i'd be
down i mean
again as i said in the pre the pre-game
interview um
i've never played a game of chess in my
life but just within these last couple
of weeks i've grown
so much more of an appreciation towards
this game and i'm definitely
nowhere near as good as i think i can
get to with uh with some more practice
and whatnot so uh yeah i definitely want
to like keep that going
and uh yeah i don't know just the whole
the whole learning uh
session just from you know zero to
basically now was just so much fun
and uh really an eye opener for me yeah
and wrestage uh we saw actually a grand
master
on twitter reach out to you uh earlier
today and offer some of his time
i'm trying to learn you gonna take him
up on that yeah of course
of course i already have he taught me
that new overlay that i used at this
game
but i used it wrong i did it on the
wrong side both times
yeah who is that who's a huge anime fan
the thing is i was using the same two
openings and i didn't want to
uh keep doing that because i knew i
talked about in my post-match interview
and i knew that jerry would know about
them however
i did it on the wrong side i was
i was i was supposed to do it on king's
side on the
and i did it on queen side for some
reason and
that immediately knocked my confidence
to be fair to be fair i did not know
the two openings that you were doing so
both of those openings you did i was
just kind of crashing i don't even know
if doing it on queen side is even like
an opening that people do that might
have just been like
a bunch of mistakes like
um but yeah i well don't don't uh don't
get discouraged and don't lose your
confidence man and seriously that's not
just the uh the
the uh politically correct thing to say
that but no seriously you
i think there were a lot of things you
guys both did that over the last couple
weeks just watching you guys on your
streams and
seeing you seeing you grow in the event
here it's it's been it's pretty awesome
when you see
people that are smart and motivated take
to the game you guys get better
really fast and i think sometimes it's
easy to get overwhelmed you know
and remember the negative moments but
you you did play the opening on the
wrong side of the board and we did
highlight that and we highlighted that
if you had fixed that it would have been
probably totally different but at the
same time
you got you got really interesting
positions and and really like you said
it was it was the queen loss that lost
the game not the opening right and i
think that um
you guys have a lot of a lot of uh i
wouldn't have would
i wouldn't have had my queen there to
lose if i did the over that's true
but you did good man and it was it was a
pleasure to have you guys play give us
our first tiebreaker of the event
can i can i quickly say thank you to
everyone watching who has been really
nice to me and not told me
uh that i'm terrible and i suck and
stuff because i know that i do but i
i appreciate everyone's support and i'm
glad people was
people are watching and stuff and i hope
to be able to come back next time if
this
isn't a thing that happens again well it
has been
our pleasure i'm going to say having
both of you and i do want to
congratulate you both
for making it to the top four of
tournament arc we're going to let you go
and uh and we'll we'll be looking for
you
no worries thank you very much thanks
guys great work
and there you have it we uh we now have
a final to uh to enjoy and
we're actually gonna do a a a little
pre-game conversation with gig
and sea dog as well and i didn't know
that okay i have a feeling that this
might be spicy guys because i think
these two have wanted this match
for for the month that we have been
planning this event and they both earned
their way to it
and we are going to hear from them
before the games begin so
stick around we'll be back very shortly
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right guys promise fulfilled we have
the players and uh
i i don't know just start throwing
verbal hands let's go
i why would i need to when i'm already
going to win
come on i mean like i'm i'm gonna scare
the [ __ ] out of corner so much that he's
gonna have to blame me on food poisoning
we'll see we'll see
connor's voice right there like why
would he need to when he's already gonna
win
sounded like the best bad guy of an
anime like he's just like you've got
this like smooth delivery like you're
just so confident
it's scary exactly exactly so connor i i
didn't realize that we offered extra
cash for best dressed
well i mean i thought you know i should
be the true villain of the show and
so yeah this is an anime suit yeah this
is one of the famous jojo
suits that you've got i thought i would
dress to impress you know
are you getting yourself another one
after you defeat giggup or gigger
gazette not even going to be
i mean i shouldn't have to celebrate
right it should be expected right so
you know how i feel it is is that
connor's the final boss of this
tournament dark
right i'm the protagonist i need to take
down the final boss
we'll see we'll see games either way
yeah i just want some good games but jt
this is this is an interesting moment
for you because you coached both of
these players
all the way to the final and now
i'm telling you that you have to choose
oh wow uh sophie sophie's choice how
could you do that to the man
um well i'm going to be a bit vain here
connor did shout me out on twitter so um
that's what i thought that's all it
takes well it takes
a good villain wood bribes everyone
right
as uh as the guy that said and he that
he that he picked on her to start but i
admitted
off stream just now that i've been
watching giggup more than any of the
other participants all
say that you've regardless of what
happens gig it's been it's been awesome
to see where it goes and i i don't know
i don't know what's going to happen here
i mean connor's
conor's the villain who needs to be
defeated for a reason right he is the
favorite but i can't wait to see what
you guys give us over the next hour so
all right i mean it should be
interesting we've played we've played a
few times before irs
games um it's been very pretty close
games so we
we hope we can bring that level to the
stream
and to the tournament well we won't
waste any more time we'll let you get
ready because in a few minutes we're
going to start your game so
good luck and uh we will see you after
the match
and one of you will be tournament arc
champion good luck good luck guys good
luck guys
and there they go they're gonna get
ready we're gonna get ready
uh another speedy commercial break
brought to you by
toilet paper it's not just a good idea
it's the law
we'll be right back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and we're back and the first game of the
tournament arc final starts
now oh my gosh here we go
let's go i'm super pumped by the way
they delivered on that trash talk
especially connor that's why he used my
faith i loved that villain role
i loved it that was awesome
jt you've got to be excited to watch how
this turns out huh
oh man yeah trash day's top two already
so it's like
i've already won it's great but let's
watch this
seriously you did a great job as a coach
charlie i mean it's not really a
competition of the coaches in that way
but you did a great job i mean like
they they did um you know i was very
impressed with the way
joey the anime man handled the blitz and
so if you continue to give us insights
in terms of what you gave these two guys
i'll be interested to see what happens
but look at the scotch by the way
yeah so
[Music]
can you tell us like the main ideas in
the scotch
with pleasure
people have only ever said danny quit
the scotch danny can you tell us how bad
the scotch is danny it's a drink not an
opening
oh my god i'll give you the main ideas
of the scotch all night
um okay so the main point is you're just
you're opening the center
rather than putting pressure on the
center with moves like bishop b5 and a
lopez
um bishop to b5 in a lopez or bishop c4
in an italian uh the whole point of the
scotch is to
to be aggressive and open the center
early and this is the kind of line right
here
wow that can really be good for gigguk
because
they always say don't bring your queen
out early right charlie we've told our
students that for years
but if you can put the most powerful
lady on the board in the middle of the
board and she can't be attacked why
would you not want your queen in the
center right that's
that's the problem with the move that uh
uh
sea dog played he took on d4 which is
not a good move here because you don't
want to bring the most powerful piece on
the board
into the middle of the board unless you
have a way to attack her
and here black doesn't and so white
white should have just taken the free
pawn
for some reason gig didn't do that but
he's still in good shape even without
taking the free pawn
as the computer shows white is already
clearly better here in the scotch
good for me yeah and are we gonna are we
gonna hear some frustration
if we listen in on sea dog and about uh
about having to figure this out so early
let's listen in
he's taking a deep think here
god this is a fiesta
you might be right danny that that queen
in the middle of the board might be
frustrating him
he looks like he's calculating his
maniacal evil plan
a good chin stroke is uh 101 for
evil geniuses so one of the things that
i told
is that oh wow interesting uh
interesting oh
oh boy he covered his old mouth
oh i just gave him a piece what am i
doing gave up a piece and blew out my
eardrums i think
i didn't think i didn't think oh my
[ __ ] oh my goodness gracious what have i
just done
oh my god he's gonna spot that this is
this is shocking oh
oh my god he didn't spot it oh my god
okay what the [ __ ] i'm just gonna take
it
wow sea dog dodged a massive bullet just
now
i i wonder if there's a bit of gigguk
sorry
throwing my phone away off camera i
wonder if there's a bit of giga who
didn't
okay i don't agree with the psychology
too much but we know the relationship
between the guys we know the history has
been that conor is the better player
right
and sometimes when you know you're the
worst player in the two and you have
that sort of history it's like a little
brother big brother syndrome
you don't expect the blunder and i think
gig
just didn't even realize the bishop on
b4 was hanging here
he just didn't even expect the blunder
and so he just missed it
um so yeah a lot of what happened with
giga is that i told him that he has a
one player style
right that he just wants to play his
plans and not really care about what his
opponent plays
and so the thing that i told him is like
okay we have to play this kind of 1.5
player chess
where basically you identify your
opponent's threats first you eliminate
your opponent's threats and then you go
with your plans
right and so that's the kind of stuff
that i took him in and
i think that he was just going for his
plans a little too much without
identifying first what he was trying to
do
and that it was actually a blunder
and you know it could also be you know
we drill the opening principles
into the beginner's head so heavily that
we have to also remember
to have them still have that awareness
before each move don't just make your
opening moves but also like
you know check the situation each time
yep
yeah we always say every piece of advice
is a guide it's a plan these days it's
your it's your siri it's your map quest
but you still have to control the wheel
with everything that pops in front of
you as you drive you know
and i think that uh you know we'll see
how that goes we'll see how gigan
responds to that whether he even knows
maybe the best thing for giger right now
is he maybe doesn't even know that he
missed an opportunity yet
right because psychologically it can be
harder to recover when you know you
messed up
um so we'll see i think that conor
connor's position is still
a bit of trouble potentially now with
this check so if giger doesn't know that
he blundered guys he might still think
he's doing well here
just psychologically and i i want to go
into giga
game because he just played a giga brain
move guys like
queen e5 i think was the best move in
that position
and i would love to yeah yeah let's
listen to see
why he made that decision
it's fine by me um i guess now i can
start trading right
okay cook says he likes that right
very interesting the time is about
evening you know sea dog is up
up 30 seconds but he's thinking right
now
and then i can develop my bishop there
and block his queen so then i can castle
either side
very nice yep eyeing bishop d3 so that
he can potentially castle either
kingside or queenside
and he can do it um whatever conor wants
to
show his plan he seems calm
i suppose he would want to move his
knight there to get my queen
off yep
saw that one coming um
where's the best position to move my
queen
can't move there because then he'll
trade
hmm well can i move there no he'll get a
free bishop there
um
you know danny made a very interesting
observation
which is you know that you wondered
whether or not knowing he missed that
free peace
was or wasn't affecting him and it seems
like
obviously we don't know whether he did
or didn't see it but
either way he's composed so
i thought you were going to say the
observation i made of the poster behind
gigguk along with the twitch chat but
yes
i also made an observation earlier about
the um
oh okay so he backs up there and again
now i'm going to be a little more
aggressive in my psychological profiling
as a coach
i tend to chess is very much psychology
and you tend to learn very quickly like
potential traits
of strength and weakness in the way
someone approaches the game but as a
coach
i try not to be too early like
impressing my view on it and projecting
because i may be bringing in past
experiences
but now i'm sure of it like gig is not
being aggressive enough he missed a
piece earlier on bishop b4
and now so he misses the whole piece
right and now
conor plays a threat and his whole focus
is on
the potential consequences of the threat
he's not even
looking for his winning moves here which
would be queen takes g7 this move would
be winning
pretty much on the spot and this is a
now now that i've seen enough of it it's
much more likely i can say that this is
what happens when you play someone
who has historically been better than
you it's different than playing someone
for the first time who may be better
than you you're it's a different kind of
gamesmanship there's a psychological
thing you have to make a breakthrough of
and that worries me a little bit now
that i'm seeing it in action that i just
i'm a hard time going to be picking
against conor in this match because
gigic has been winning twice now out of
the opening and he hasn't seen either
opportunity so
jt that's a thing as a coach you got to
address later too right like hey like
the psychological burden
of you know check your opponent's
mistakes too not just their threats
right he's not
looking for that opportunity right right
um
and i guess it also sends down to like
he likes to think a lot
right and and maybe
he's just only thinking about like
beautiful plans for himself and not for
his opponent's sake so i
definitely agree with you danny that's
something that we will go over in the
future
well no i didn't mean that as a coach
call out i'm not calling y'all i was
saying like it's an important
psychological thing to like recognize
that like
it's not even about his own plans he's
thinking about conor's threats like
bishop b4 was played
right in this position all he thought
about was oh i have to get rid of this
bishop what is this bishop going to do
to me what is this bishop going to do to
me
so he attacked it he didn't think at all
about the fact that bishop was hanging
right right and then and then with
knight to g4 you could just see the
cycle and again it's just
it's normal that's all i was saying is i
think that it's it's a thing that is
hard to overcome and makes an underdog
uphill battle even worse when you've had
many games against someone who was
previously better than you
right that's all anyway it's interesting
and i think it's still plenty plenty of
game ahead
and on the clock they're actually
roughly equal right
i think conor knows he probably got off
to a worse start than gig does at this
point like i think gig has missed his
opportunities and conor's probably like
you know i just don't even know that i'm
playing well i mean we'll take a listen
in to see what he's thinking but that's
that's my read on the psychology right
now
right yeah let's do that let's listen in
on connor and see
how he feels
he wants to surprise attack
connor definitely trying to guess at
giger's
plans
he's quieter than he's ever been on
stream yes
i know that he can just reveal the
bishop at the moment i want to pin the
bishop to the
rook at the moment
yeah that's a great observation jt this
is
this is a more serious sea dog than
we've seen in this competition
i want to cut off this square though as
well for the bishop i don't want to
allow it to
go there and you can't get that right
now so i guess there's no point i don't
want to have this square though either
and also that huge blunder earlier
might have changed his psyche and said
hey i can't do this again
hmm i think i should preemptively move
my queen there
see that branding yeah
let me get my queen out of the way
i need to keep this line
this may also be the first time conor's
been down on the clock in a match
e5 wow
i like it yeah yeah i expected that
jojo expected that move yeah i i thought
it was a good move and then as soon as i
said it was a good move and i found it
he found it right after me um
so are you saying that you just jojo the
jojo i jojo's the jojo wow you can't
you can't jojo with jojo actually you
can't triple stamp a double stamp and
you can't jojoba jojo
so that is a sorry no no all jojos are
linked actually
oh okay all generations of jojo's are
linked this is the anime theory
it's super anime theory
bishop d5 was a good move there though
from conor right back at it e5 was an
aggressive move and it's a clearance
move for potential tactics here
everybody but
bishop d5 was a very quick heads up
recognizes he has the chance to double
up the pressure of the queen and the
brook
on the pawn and i think you guys made
the right observation conor has been
more quiet more
focused oops didn't do that but
but i think that that's the early
hangover of he knew he didn't start out
well he saw a bishop before was hanging
remember we had him on camera
remember his reaction but now as the
game's going on
i think he's finding himself a little
bit more and
and i think um it's going to be an
unfortunate kind of review if giga goes
back and look at it where he just
doesn't realize how potentially better
he was
um because i feel i have a hard time
believing that
conor doesn't pick up that e5 pawn and
then start to be better from here on out
there he goes
it's funny yeah um but connor connor you
know he didn't know the scotch so i
don't know
where gig learned the scotch but conor
clearly had no idea what to do there
um and you know we saw something like
that from russet yesterday when he went
up against conor
he played openings that he knew conor
didn't know
interesting okay
well um gigglik is now in trouble
down upon and you know should be worse
but there's still the potential of
any anytime you have kings on opposite
sides of the board right
tactics galore always potential chances
for an attack and a blunder
um because both sides can really just
focus their efforts on the enemy king
without thinking too much about their
own
so we'll see we'll see what google comes
up here but he's now now down under four
minutes so
uh jt you work with both these guys
who's going to be the better player
when that time scramble hits from like
when the gloves come off
so i think sea dog might be
the favorite here uh if it
goes under three minutes
and the position is roughly equal i
think c dog
will be better just
guard likes to just think and he likes
to make plans he likes to make his own
ideas but
it just takes a lot of time right and i
think though
that's where the blunders are going to
happen do you like this move uh queen f4
i do uh even though it doesn't even have
a concrete threat because the queen
guards f7
um and and the rook is still guarded by
the queen i like the move though from
just uh you're putting pressure on the
king's side
there's still the potential for tactics
you kind of eye this h7 pawn
and connor connor's in blunderable
territory you see the clock ticking away
here because this is
it's got to be a little scared the rook
is sort of pinned to the queen
um yeah and does that make maybe a well
actually uh does that make something
like uh
rook d to e1 useful okay maybe it would
have been
i mean not not um okay not anymore
obviously that we're coming to e7 is
just an offering of the queen trade
and you have to be careful with moves
like rook dd1 if that rook could have
taken with check
then uh then it would have been a
reverse pins could be reverse
discoveries that's the thing about pins
we have to be careful about right if you
can move the pin piece with a tempo
then you actually win the material
behind it so a pin becomes a discovered
attack
but either way connor gets a heads up
kind of token from me
did you know i give up heads i give out
heads-up tokens no it's
he gets a heads up joking because he
just eliminates all of it and just says
i'm up a pawn
i'm just going to get the pieces off the
board that's a heads up play from connor
it's really interesting like even this
middle game
is very interesting and i think
like we always have to worry about the
g4 pawn after let's say we started trade
and i started the g2 pawn and
do we want to trade right and are they
going to take control of the open files
if we have to worry about our g-pawn
right so these are things that
i'm just thinking about and there's
still a lot of play here even
at my level where i think even at
everybody's level i think there's a lot
of play here
and you know what gig was uh eyeing that
rook that we just talked about
but settles on a different move
let's listen in to see how he is going
to redirect his pieces to get into
tackling
this is damn difficult okay now i'm
going to start pushing phones up
[Music]
sorry that was awkward a bad guy into me
whoa that was a mistake right that was a
mistake by him recognizing
that it's a mistake
that gives me an opening right are we
gonna have history in the making here
i'm not gonna says he has never won a
game
against okay he's given me an opening
he's given me an opening
and now he's fighting oh and it's it's
amazing
wow wow wow wow give him an opening
is he sweating he must be sweating he
must be sweating
really damn bad now
this is really scary if i were conor i
would be so scared in this position
working it out meanwhile let's check in
with connor and see how he's dealing
with this new
this new threat yeah take a look
throwing i'm throwing so hard
oh my gosh
what is happening
i don't want to say anything my goodness
it was made in one it was made in one
oh my god i didn't want to say anything
queen takes f8 would have been
lights out right yeah yeah a moment ago
oh no
and it seems like conor knows he's in
danger but didn't
have a sense how much time though so i'm
pretty sure you can do it
for sure get good with less than a
minute
but still if giggit doesn't win this
game guys
it's because he just didn't realize how
potentially good his position
was multiple times including a mate in
one
and now he's under a minute he has to be
very careful here because
there are a lot of mates
i would love to see giger's perspective
here because he's the one that's
attacking
what is he thinking yeah i mean sea dogs
got time to think but gigeok on the
other hand
has to use what little time left he has
to come after him he has to do something
let's go
40 a few a few seconds here there's only
a few seconds left
sea dog allowing some very dangerous
things to happen oh
checkmate one second there's a
checkpoint come on come on
okay i'm just gonna start trading pieces
oh my [ __ ] god
come on come on come on
game [ __ ] game on
game on wow
wow screaming game on holy [ __ ]
wow what a game believe that
connor's saying he cannot believe it
this is i
guys we what this could be a crazy upset
so
i'm shocked that giga eventually won the
game not because
he didn't play better but i feel like he
was missing all of his opportunities
and then finally when it when it was
when push came to shove he he finally
delivered
delivered on the most important one
which is a checkmate one movement
so that's history gig has never beaten
conor until now
conor the heavy favorite to win
tournament arc is now down one nothing
it's win or go home for sea dog
wow at this point the rating difference
really means nothing
these two players can beat each other
and and so
game two sea dog has the white pieces
and
he must win he cannot just draw
he has to beat gigguk right now to stay
in the in the running for for the
championship
and you know what's very interesting is
that they've played many times and
it's just like casual games like if you
play blitz and you know it's not in a
tournament setting it kind of just
doesn't really hold as much weight but
when you're in a tournament setting
that win matters that much more and
you're concentrating and you're thinking
even harder
so i think that's what happened here and
maybe conor was a little bit lacks and
said
well i mean i beat him so many times
yeah i wonder if conor is going to give
up
exactly what he was feeling if we listen
in right now in these opening moves
let's go push this
i can't believe that i can't believe it
conor's still reeling from that first
loss and look at gigguk he's playing
this sort of suffocating chest that
we've seen him practice
that 1.5 player chess
okay
this is the most intense and quiet we've
seen conor
i think he's feeling the pressure
wow wow this is this is so
intense this is
this is rough you know this is uh it's
very interesting
to see um when a person
who was the favorite now loses a game
and now
they're they are in a must-win situation
yeah and i wonder if uh the hangover of
like finally losing to someone who i
think that sea dog has known that google
is getting better and better and better
i mean conor has been
the favorite here in a lot of people's
eyes for good reason but
has been improving and i think now you
know does he find himself
right really really uh bring out bring
out the best
the best in his chest which he i i
thought he was on
pace to do it last game before this g5
move and i think you said it jt maybe he
just
got overconfident got a little wax
because it was just such a horrible
horrible blunder but um but now
now we'll see white should be better
here if he finds the right moves i mean
he should find a way to maybe trade the
knights on d4
okay and then bring the queen out i
thought maybe to the jack f7
this is this is risky opening the door
for black to get a lot of camera play
here
um and indeed look at giga he plays rook
b8 very quickly
yeah he may have been thinking well
let's destroy the pawns on the other
side making the prospect of castling
pretty ugly in either direction but
the yikes that's a good point that's a
good point art
um that could have been what what connor
is thinking as far as getting rid of the
pawn here because the black king doesn't
have safety on this side of the board
long term now that giga has already
advanced the pawns
so that that's a really that's a really
good point and i think that even if the
computers objectively think black is
okay here
it is interesting as long as conor gets
castle
and his king is safe from a practical
point of view black is going to have a
lot to figure out
about where this king is safe in the
long term
and jt i know you've talked to gigguk
about you know things like
king safety and stuff like that do you
think he's gonna
he's gonna look at this situation and
just make a decision to go on an
all-out attack or i think he will
actually i think he's gonna go all out
he's winning you know that's the psyche
like okay like now that i'm winning i
really have to take this opportunity
and try to like punish him
well let's listen in because we see a
lot of talk coming out of that camera
and
he must be sharing his plans so let's
listen to them
considering the trade
what's he gonna do
if i check him
goes for a check and you should notice
here that sea dog is playing extremely
quickly
after 14 moves only down 45 seconds
yeah he's got to be thinking on his
opponent's turn which is
what can i do how important i how can i
how can i keep applying this pressure
okay he says he wants to continue to
apply pressure he's trapped my rook
that was very good advantage from him to
notice that
and and how amazing would it be
if we had two games that ended up in the
two matches that ended up in the blitz
tie break on the final stream
on the season finale you can't ask for
anything better than that but uh
maybe we maybe we don't even get there
because there have to be
tactics uh lying in wait here on this
side of the board right
mm-hmm weave in the twitch chat said he
thought bishop b3 was very impressive by
conor to find the retreating defensive
move i agree
we know gig is on the attack uh jt
what kind of attacking moves do you
think we might see
i mean i think this is going to be
really hard for him to find
but now that you are basically
dominating
on the queen side you should start
thinking about other parts of the board
and well there are two two options right
there's one keep attacking on the queen
side but i think that option is just
limiting your options
and i think you should start attacking
on the king side now that you have now
that all of the pieces kind of shifted
over to the queen side
for defense because the biggest problem
though for black is that the rook is
potentially trapped
so queen of six is played
he's bringing out pieces like you said
but a lot of conor's problems are solved
if he just gets the king
out of the center if he gets castle here
and everything opens up the knight is no
longer pinned
so you have threats of knight c4 the
rook is suddenly a big
problem this is this could be a really
dangerous lesson per gig
if he if depending very good for conor
he finally castles because here's the
thing like even from a practical point
of view
now gig has to find all the best moves
to hold on with a rook that has
wandered so far from home right
i mean there's already a threat and i
see boris that's right on the board yeah
right um this is this is going to be a
really big moment for giggup
uh-oh that's that's the kind of what
happens in a position like this without
the best move from here on out
all of a sudden your brook has just has
gone i mean queen c1
and knight c4 okay lol not queen c1
wow danny but the idea of the rookie job
like okay connor
connor doesn't play as bad as me big
surprise
and finds knight c4 but you get what i'm
saying the rook has gone too far
but honestly if that night on d4
and now they have a lot of dark square
weaknesses right so that bishop is going
to be great
and in comparison to the white star
square bishop is really bad
yeah that's totally true i mean but
again it's going to come down to the
material i think that
i think that now that the rook is
trapped
[Music]
oh yeah i think connor's sending us to
our second tie break of the day wow
did we not get the finale we wanted or
not people come on
and i told you this is going to be the
highest
episode of the tournament i told you
guys
yesterday i told you guys in my twitter
post i told you guys
oh i'm so excited this is this is okay i
mean
gig is going to be all in now with an
attack and like you said he was feeling
aggressive he's winning in the match all
that stuff and i
i think i don't think it was the wrong
psychology but
every player in their growth learns
lessons of things like a rook takes b2
where you learned that it was a good
idea but maybe you missed
the potential consequence and bishop b3
by chess weave pointed out grandmaster
uh boros in the twitch yet he's totally
right this was a heads up play
it doesn't matter that black maybe with
perfect plate was still okay but that
trapped the rook
and that that's gonna ultimately be why
conor won the game as that bishop e3
move
well i would like to see what conor is
thinking right yeah i'm
super excited i'm wondering if he's
breathing a sigh of relief
um
it was definitely a sigh yeah
you can't do anything immediately hmm
okay he knows his king is safe right
i can't really do anything with the
pawns either
but on a second look the king side does
seem a bit shaky for white yeah
maybe with a good sacrifice giga can get
in and we have the first
muda of the day
i knew it was an anime reference oh yeah
it's a super anime reference yeah
i laugh because i don't know things i do
that as a dad a lot i think
my night back around was a good day if
you say that
fair enough
conor's still thinking about that first
game he mentioned that uh
that was a sour experience for him just
now
and he's probably not feeling too
comfortable there's a fork now obviously
but there's no way he can get it
no way no way
wow all these pieces are eyeing the
king's side i i i just
i need to know how black gets through
well but conor seems to feel
i mean obviously giga was the one on the
clock there and trying to come up with
something and i think connor had
calculated he wanted to play this f3
move
which is a little risky but overall it's
it's hard to lose this if he makes a
trade or i think what conor's plan is i
think he likes the idea of bringing this
bishop here to trade off
this sort of meddling meddling bishop on
c5 which is a nice plan
to try to bring the bishop here to trade
off the attacker and indeed he does it
that's what i predicted when he played
f3 that his
it wasn't necessary he could have traded
the bishop for the night other things
but i think he spied this bishop as his
problem
which is a good it's a good uh
it's a good sign of technique meaning
when you're better
you just recognize what are the biggest
pain points let's eliminate them one
pain point at a time because again
that's just
the chest uh psychology should always be
if you're winning you should always win
and you do that by being disciplined and
by just eliminating your problems
so i like the idea of bishop f2 even if
it wasn't totally necessary it shows
that he saw this this problem
so and and what about uh h3 instead of
trading the bishops first
i think i think either way um gigging
knows he's all in right now
he's he's pushing harry up the board
right if conor makes a horrible mistake
like to make a trade on the h-file
something that
brings life to the black pieces he could
get in trouble
i think if he finds the move g3 this
game will be over
um but if he oh
that's like i said if he finds g3
h6
we have to listen in our gig right now
and see if he sees
yeah that's the fork right and he can't
take free rook
it's fine by me oh
what a turn of fence and now we're back
even now we're back even
let's go
now danny he just said something very
interesting that cues you into the
psychology he said now we're back
even does he not realize he's doing so
much better than that
he's focused on the material part of it
because he because remember
this the biggest pain point in giga's
brain is that he lost his rook on b2
back on move 17 right so his whole
psychology is okay now we're even i've
got my rook back
and i think that's already okay
but i i do think it continues to show
gig sort of psychological perspective is
that
he's just trying to stay with conor i
think gingka has had a
healthy underdog mindset coming into
this match that has kept him super
focused
because and yes it led to missed
opportunities in that first game that i
highlighted
but ultimately it's proving to pay off
because
one of the best things you can do as a
chess player is to just never rest on
your laurels it's okay if you're winning
to think you're close to even
because as long as you're objectively
find the best move it doesn't matter
right you don't need to have the
emotional
comfort of thinking you're winning or
losing like just find the best move and
i think that
i think gigging's mindset is actually
really clear i think conor is just
clearly off his game right now he's just
not considering gigger's threats
which is why he missed this h-shakes g2
check
i'm i'm just blown away right now i'm
sorry this is just crazy to me i just
really thought conor was
really a heavy favorite and and he is
he's not in his best chess and if queen
takes f3 is played here
omg's are snaps get your emotes out yeah
he's feeling it let's listen in
wow connor is feeling the heat
you know i would say he's not letting it
show but
his silence kind of says the whole story
this is the muta muda muda check after
check after check after check
no mistake oh yeah what's a buddha
buddha buddha
[Laughter]
he said it we'll educate we'll educate
you later dude
yeah okay we'll sit you down
we'll teach you the ways yeah we'll have
a anime one-on-one
uh lesson for you we'll show you the
hormone the hammer
end of the greatness ah okay
and great moves being played right
no it's not [ __ ] my god
conor is definitely feeling the heat
yeah you see he's desperate to
desperate for her to make a mistake and
he's not making one
if you're this is tough
yeah that's a bad sign right there the
last thing we saw with connor
uh before we switched away the fact that
he was arrowing through this yes
yes i was just about to it means he's
living in the past and he's frustrated
with the mistakes that he's made this is
uh
i've had so many lessons on this both in
terms of training that i was given by
grandmasters and by
you know training with my students that
he's just
he's just not like the fact that he was
better earlier but still beating himself
up about the game before remember
right before he blundered he's just not
he's just not present right now and
that's a normal thing that happens when
you've like
decided i'm better i should win and so
you just keep thinking
that if it's not going your way that the
story is you've done something wrong you
just you have to remain present and he's
you can't be second-guessing moves
mid-game do that after the game
but i will say that one thing i'll give
conor credit for if he comes back if he
finds queen e2 here oh he does okay
i'm gonna make a bold prediction conor
wins this game because the one thing he
did
was even when things went off went off
the rails and when things were not
what he wanted them to be he kept the
tempo and he's going to win this game
because of time
i really think so that's gonna pay off i
like your prediction
actually danny yeah giggling's only got
a minute left on the clock let's listen
in because he's work
he's gotta go fast no
yeah cause he can't move his queen in
the way
we talk about this all the time getting
the initiative you have to be able to
keep it
mm-hmm
under a minute wow this is tough um
you know this is that what now moment
right
your attack seems to have finished
do i want to call some now oh i'm
running out of time
[ __ ]
i want to get my queen i want to get my
queen out there
i'm going to be living on increments
soon that's that's bad
okay so lisey understands the concept of
being able to gain some time
by moving quickly [ __ ] yeah the
increment concept
but i i still think it's going to be too
little too late
i've i've i've not got enough time to
think about this i'm just going to offer
up the queen trade
he can take it if because then i got my
rook up here
connor issuing the check first
burns more time on giga's clock
like queen trade yeah [ __ ] it
and conor five minutes on the clock
i've got to win this through increment
now okay gotta gotta
gotta start gotta start planning this
out quick okay
so here we go
the goal is to move fast
the checks will keep coming making a
difference
yes yes
oh my goodness oh man
look i can't say anything this is crazy
seconds on the clock white is winning is
this over is this there
that rook is hanging is this that
is this [ __ ] it
neither of them see it
he's just living on increment
my pawns are trapped in the corner oh
this game's lost
this game's [ __ ] lost wow we are
going to go to tie break
there's nothing i can do
i don't know yet i mean connor hasn't
put it away
there's nothing i can do i've lost
i've lost ah giggook is already
basically
a really beautiful move here hopefully
we are able to see it
he's he's emotionally divested from this
game
yeah but he shouldn't be it's too bad
because
neither player realizes that rook on h4
is for free
that's a free run it's almost like c
doug thinks he
only also has 13 seconds on his glock
yeah and c
dog did the right thing earlier which is
why i predicted he would come back and
win because he kept the pressure and got
gigguk under this horrible time
now he's finally slowing down now if he
takes a second
and just gets back to playing the best
move on the board he's going to win the
game
um because at this point white isn't
even objectively
losing even if the rook saves itself
like white is not
worse here so by the way the book did
save itself
um
as long as as long as conor plays good
moves here he'll actually be fine
this is a really tense game wow yeah
dude
this is no i and i think david might
realize now
it's funny he was emotionally kind of
like not through in the towel but he
just figured it was a matter of time
before he lost on time
now i think he i think he uh
i think maybe he he realizes he still
has a brook
uh-oh maybe for not for long
will conor see the fork there is
a killer can we see can we see what
carter's thinking right now yes let's
see if he spots it
he can guarantee almost
the tie break
putting a lot of pressure on himself as
well he is but he's not moving too
quickly he sees that he's got three and
a half minutes on the clock
you could hear a pin drop all the way in
tokyo
oh and he cannot repeat if he repeats he
loses
oh boy
remember the stakes everyone a draw wins
the tournament for gig
if he repeats with the knight to c5 it's
a draw
oh
i don't know if he knows three move
repetition if black plays king c7 it's a
draw
oh no don't play king c7 please oh
by repetition what
can we see but
oh my god what how is that a draw by
repetition
[Music]
oh
oh my god oh my god
what's chat saying what is chat saying
this was the most anime this was the
most anime final
you could possibly hope for [ __ ] oh
unbelievable
the protagonist wins
gig by repetition
oh my gosh who could have predicted this
um
he gets the half point he needs seals
the deal the tournament is over gigguk
has one tournament arc
oh m geezer snaps right oh my gosh
it's so crazy and the way that we got
here was so
wild and and it was just
not the way you expect the championship
to be won with the repetition
especially because like conor learned
such a harsh lesson there which is that
it's about whether the position repeats
three times look how hard this is wow
well because this is okay i think maybe
you remember something here
but before we before we dive in though
maybe we ought to save the chest for the
players
let's get them on camera and uh we
oh my goodness guys we'll take a break
we'll be right back with
giga can see dog don't go anywhere
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
with a minute and a half left on the
commercial break clock i just decided no
we can't wait we have to come back
this is a this was amazing you guys were
incredible i
i think jt has has uh i think uh jt
has a theory about why the the fates
were in order to end the way that they
did jt go ahead
all right guys stay with me it's gonna
be a little bit long
but it's gonna be great all right so
connor was the villain we all know this
he was antagonist
not for me but go ahead and guard was
the protagonist right
and so connor was always stronger
than guard in chess does it sound
familiar hold on it'll
start to get there right now he's always
he's always been stronger he's always
won
every single fight but after training
for so long
guard built up that muslim when things
got tough
even though he had his jojo suit on but
he had the mind of an
evil genius good
and justice prevailed i i didn't know
that second game was going to draw i
didn't know that
and i i i didn't think you i didn't
think you did and
regardless of the as jt is pointing out
the plot armor of this thing
and people talking about it but i
i didn't see that i thought you were
going to get the w here and i think at a
point
giga thought he was going to lose too
but i i said
to chad right before we went to break
and saw a point that you learned a
really harsh lesson about
uh the draw rules of chess which is that
i do
if the position occurs three times it
doesn't matter if the moves are
different
oh so so this position on boom 52
i just clicked it you can't even see it
because it's the same position this
position on move 52 was the same
and you knew you you knew you were
repeating and so you knew you had to do
something different
yeah but if you get the same position
even though that those last two moves
got there be a different way it's
actually
we were on the edge of our seat and just
uh heart hearts throbbing like oh my god
does he not know that if he plays knight
to see
no i didn't oh man
that was my plot that was my secret
technique all along that was like
i thought i used to finish it yeah i
thought because the move was different
it would be okay and then i was about to
like start pushing pawns but
really unfortunate because i think i
could have done it as well but oh
no there you go and that's that is
unfortunate because it's a it's a it's a
rule that
you know you learned a a harsh lesson
because it is
three-fold repetition three-fold
position
three-fold repetition of the position
not the moves and that's a weird
it sounds silly because yes obviously if
the same exact moves are played three
times the same position occurs
but if the same position occurs even if
it takes 150 moves which is unlikely but
that's
that's the lesson of this is that it
doesn't matter if the moves are
different
i hate i hate to dive into the chess
weeks but it's just such a weird way for
that to end and
you guys gave us quite the show though
thank you and
honestly so there was a lot of stuff
that happened there and i
i want danny to show us a little bit
more um because honestly it was amazing
chess
um and i'm really proud i said this
before but i am proud of the chess that
you guys have played
throughout this whole tournament like
you guys have really really made me
proud and
it shows in your game that you've just
gotten better since day one and months
grand master chest weed was in the chat
uh dennis boros who's the big anime fan
and he was applauding your move right
here
conor bishop to b3 a fantastic one
that was a really good move yeah i
wanted to trap him in though
yeah and that was exactly a fantastic
move
and and it's nice to know yeah you had
the thought process it wasn't even just
about defending the pawn
with the bishop which it does but it
traps the rook and
and i i don't think we jinxed it but at
a certain point
you know you won the rook and and we
were like you know if conor goes on to
win this game
it's because of this brilliant bishop e3
move yeah and then and then the
follow-up
um but then giga you you went kind of
full
beast mode here and you just started
throwing everything at the king's side
yeah because conor castled and that was
that was my that was like my go
button because how how i saw it is that
that rook was lost
right right but all connor's all of
connor's pieces were on that side of the
board
and then he castled so what i saw was
just okay
he can take that piece he can waste time
taking that piece i'm going to use that
time
to set up my attack on the ki um on the
castle
side of the board and and basically
see how he deals with it because none of
this my king wasn't
wasn't in any threat so i was just gonna
see if i could make threats on his king
and see how he handles that instead
connor you you you had a good plan with
this
f3 move because your focus was on
eliminating the bishop
yeah did you did you just miscalculate
that he takes on g2 with check
is that what happened yeah i i didn't i
didn't think it enough i should have
stayed longer but i realized when the
bishop had been put
sorry uh when he started pushing the
pawn on the the the
h-file i was like oh no i should have
pushed my pawn too early or at least one
at that point i should have raised the
pawn one and i would completely stop
this attack and it would have been done
uh
i i think i just panicked and i know i
shouldn't have uh but
yeah it's my bad i i know i had that
game as well uh
but yeah it's unfortunate i just missed
it no i mean
we're and we have no reason to review it
other than enjoying it with you guys you
guys played so
so well and and even after this i was
applauding the fact that you knew you
were worse but you
you stayed up on the clock and that was
leading to our final
kind of you know climactic moment here
where you were you were up on the clock
and and if you hadn't avoided the draw
if you had avoided the job maybe you
still win
what was your mindset there to just dig
yourself out of the time pressure hole
because look at look at this right here
in the timeline
right right here you were literally
let's see no you were literally at one
point living off the increment you made
a move with like a second on the clock
yeah yeah right here um my i okay so
there was a point when i had just given
up and i was just like okay let's just
play this out to the end
right then i realized that um
uh when i got my work in working last
position that i can possibly just play
this out for a draw because
it's on connor to win this because i i
only need a draw
um so i just try to make it as annoying
as possible
i didn't want to give him anything for
free um and
yeah just played out for the draw that
was that was my that was
my tactic i realized it was a mistake
giving away my bishop as well it was
pinning down the two pieces and the pawn
shouldn't have done that
well we don't even need to dive more to
the chest i mean obviously uh you guys
have had
an amazing event and brought us all the
way to the championship i've been
watching as a fan
my first commentary experience here did
not disappoint
um and so you guys are awesome at what
you do
and thanks for uh thanks for competing
in this event and uh
and doing what we do i guess doing some
chess here for for this week so this has
been awesome
yep and uh thank you very much and and
connor i
uh i'm expecting a message on twitter
from you
very shortly asking about the dates of
the
comeback arc tournament am i right we'll
need round two we'll need round two for
sure
for sure gotta claim my my rifle graham
got robbed
deal brendo never dies that's true
i'm just glad that the only the only
time i've ever beaten corner was on the
biggest stage i just did man i don't
know man that first game i have no idea
what i was doing it was just a complete
mess
i don't know yeah protagonist power
activate right yeah it doesn't matter
what happens in training
what matters in the final tournament i
mean i
thank you so much guys this was
absolutely unbelievable we
we everyone uh chess.com here uh the
viewers
i know that we are all super grateful
that you
came out here and you showed us your
best chess and um
we're gonna we're gonna keep an eye on
you both and um
and i imagine we'll be talking soon
about uh about some future opportunities
to
to play some more chess together what do
you think
exactly yeah i'd love it yeah i'd be
down this was a very very
fun experience um considering this was
the first time i've played chess since
like middle school or something so it's
been really fun to come back
well congratulations to both of you and
um and thank you so much and
and we'll see you around on the world
wide web
all right awesome thank you for having
us bye guys bye
yeah bye and there you have it that's it
takes home the bacon he gets the 2 000
prize and is crowned tournament arc
champion wow
do you believe it we came all this way
and um
and and and giga takes it
i'm i'm shocked honestly i think and i
don't know what it is about
about the final i mean maybe it is just
some weird you know
anime tournament arc curse that you guys
put on things with the plot with the
plot armor but it was
i i i'm just shocked and it's not taking
anywhere from gigic i think conor just
clearly
didn't have his best chess in this last
couple games but that gig
has come so far i've said i've watched
more of his streams than anyone else
but like he said conor said he was like
i just played terrible that first game
and and then he got a little bit unlucky
with this draw role here
that a lot of beginner players would
know but at the same time
wow what drama we had and giga had the
right mindset he was like all i got to
do is get a draw here so as he explained
himself
he clearly did everything he needed to
do to win uh this championship so
and jt are you happy with the result
i mean yeah i mean at the end of the day
i
i was rooting for the villain but the
protagonist always wins and the flat
armor is just so
thick and i mean but deal brendo never
dies and
we'll see we'll see this happen and
unfold real soon
well i i guess this is before we wrap up
my opportunity
to thank a lot of people obviously i
want to thank the players
sid snap rustic the anime man revel
house mother's basement super eye patch
wolf sea dog gig
and uh and then of course thank my
co-host japanese tutor for not only
being my co-commentator
all the way up to the finals but also
coaching uh the players and
offering your youtube content after the
fact you've got lessons out there
uh that you had with the players on your
youtube channel um
and then and then the staff behind the
scenes of course uh chris
who's helping out with the event and um
and uh
our new event manager you know who you
are i know you're watching
and then of course danny i i brought
this idea to you
about a month ago after i reached out to
connor and he expressed that he
wanted to rally the anime community if i
could rally the chess community in
uh you remember that call i was super
super nervous
bringing this to chess.com but um i have
to thank you for saying
yes and making this possible and um
and for joining us tonight of course my
it's my absolute pleasure and like i
said
and again i was like why did why did you
present this idea earlier this is
awesome this is amazing and it's been
some of the coolest
some of the coolest just uh not only
the the way that the event was presented
the community behind it i mean all those
of you in chat those of you may be
watching later you know who you are it's
been so cool to see
the anime community rally behind it and
also just have a ton of fun watching
more people you know engage with chess
and understand that there's
there's the growth of getting better is
is a big part of the fun right and i
think that
we we have so many amazing events with
the world's best chess players
going on all the time on chess.com but
these events are
uh in some ways just like super special
in terms of the drama and the growth you
see of the players throughout the last
couple weeks
watching where they've come and this is
awesome so shout out to connor
and the whole anime the whole anime crew
that committed to this and aaron for
having the uh
the the brainchild that has become
tournament arc so
super excited about what this was uh
thanks danny and then last
of course i want to thank my beautiful
wife for making sure that i look
gorgeous and feel good every day before
i come and do the show and thank the
viewers
all of you out there you came every
single night
and um and get at us on twitter
let us know when you want to see the
comeback arc begin
uh thank you thank you thank you and
we'll see you around
good night everybody
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you